because of the coronavirus shutdown
nevada faced a 1.2
billion dollar budget shortfall that's
about a quarter of the state's budget
but the cuts will fill that hole orca
mana joins us live in studio now with
what programs are being affected here
orca well sasha after 12
long days the nevada legislature has
finally balanced the budget for the next
fiscal year
while lawmakers were able to slightly
lower the amount of cuts
to state agencies some k-12 education
programs
and nevada's health care system will
still be negatively impacted
we came in with heavy hearts and our
hearts are still heavy
a stressful special session ends for
nevada lawmakers the last crucial budget
bill passing in both chamber sunday
the vote on assembly bill number three
is 21 years zero nays
despite restoring more than 130 million
dollars of funding state agency budgets
will still be severely slashed
around 160 million dollars will be cut
from k-12 education
although 50 million dollars in federal
cares act funding will be given for
alternative programming to help students
directly impacted by coven 19
other cuts to programs for low achieving
students and the read by three program
will impact thousands of children
statewide
these programs that we thought were
important and that we as a legislature
should have prioritized
over some of the other restorations that
are represented in this bill
a couple hundred million dollars will
also be cut from nevada's health care
system lawmakers were able to save
around 50 million in medicaid programs
including dental
behavioral health and hospice services
but many of the nearly 500 thousand
nevadans on medicaid will still be
affected
we must prioritize that funding for the
nevada medicaid budget
again when nevada's economy improves
i implore my colleagues to consider
providing the services that we were not
able
to add back lawmakers hope federal
funding will undo some of the cuts
we call on the united states senate to
take a vote to give aid to states
we call on the white house to step up
and lead but until then they're relying
on their actions now to help nevada get
by until the next legislative session i
think what we've done
is we've accomplished a bridge bridge is
a little shaky
maybe isn't as solid as we would like to
be but it's a bridge that gets us from
here today
to february governor steve sisolak has
already signed
three bills so far from the special
session he's expected to sign this
latest funding bill as well
the governor had originally planned to
call for an immediate second special
session to discuss criminal justice
reform
and unemployment insurance barriers but
because of the spike
of cobit 19 cases in nevada he does not
want to put lawmakers at risk
in a statement today he said quote i
will only do so when i am confident the
legislature has fully reviewed all
policy items
and is ready to conduct a thorough
organized and efficient special session